KENDRA PUGH: Hi.
I'd like to talk to you today
about inheritance as a
fundamental concept in object
oriented programming, its use
in Python, and also tips and
tricks for using inheritance
in Python and in the
object oriented
programming paradigm in 6.01.
First thing I'm going to do is
give a really quick crash
course on inheritance to catch
you up to speed, and also so
that you're clear on what I mean
when I say something like
parent class.
And also, I'm going to address
the sort of nuances of using
inheritance while programming
in an object
oriented fashion in Python.
A lot of the code in 6.01
uses the object oriented
programming paradigm.
And a lot of the code
in 6.01 will
inherit from parent classes.
So this is part of the
motivation for going through a
quick review, and then also
indicating the most common
slip ups, and also the most
significant things that you
may or may not have seen
from other languages.
All right, first, a crash
course on inheritance.
Let's look at the board.
Inheritance is the idea that you
can arrange objects in a
hierarchical fashion such that
very, very generalized or
basic things that are true of
a whole group of objects can
be specified at a
higher level.
And then, you can work your way
down to progressively more
specific levels.
The most formal encounter you've
probably had with this
thing, that approach, is the
biological taxonomy, right?
Kingdom, phylum, class, order,
family, genus, species.
Every species has all
the properties of
that particular genus.
All the genuses of a particular
family have the
properties of that family,
and so on, and so forth.
That's a very concrete
example.
But I find it a little boring.
So I'm going to talk about
dog breeds instead.
You're probably familiar with
the fact that golden
retrievers are a type of
retrievers and that retrievers
are a particular kind of dog.
You can make generalizations
about goldens based on what
you know about dogs, right?
All dogs bark.
All dogs have four legs if they
aren't injured or have
some sort of congenital defect,
that kind of thing.
And goldens also have
all the properties
of retrievers, right?
They are capable of going and
catching game that you've
either shot, or possibly
chase it down and
bring it back to you.
So they're bred to have very
particular properties.
Goldens are also bred to have
very particular properties.
And those that are very specific
to goldens define the
difference between a golden
versus a retriever in the
general sense.
Likewise, when we want to make
objects that have very
particular properties but also
share general properties with
other objects, we're going to
create a new category of
object and put the specifics in
that very specific category
and then take the things that we
can generalize and put them
in more general categories so
we don't end up rewriting a
lot of code.
Or we end up reusing code, but
not copying and pasting it
everywhere because
that's annoying.
The other major advantage of
using inheritance is that code
is more intuitive.
You can make references to
the same piece of code
all over the place.
But it's not as intuitively
accessible to do that over,
and over, and over
again, right?
It's really convenient to think
of the fact that golden
could be a subclass or subtype
of retriever, and that
retriever could be a subclass
or subtype of dog.
When I talk about this
relationship in terms of
object oriented programming--
when I talk about these
categories in terms of object
oriented programming and when
you're actually looking at
code, goldens are a subclass, or
child class, of retrievers.
And retrievers are
a parent class or
super class of goldens.
Likewise, dogs are a parent
class of retrievers.
So now, I've defined my
terminology and also hopefully
given you a very, very, very
quick review of inheritance.
Now, I'm going to talk about
the specifics in Python.
If I turn over here, I've
written up a very short class
definition for dog, right?
Every dog has the class
attribute, cry.
Every dog has an initialization
method that
gives every dog a very specific
name that is passed
in when you initialize
the dog.
And every dog has access to the
class method, greeting,
which returns a string that
says, "I'm," whatever the name
of the dog is, and also the
specific cry, which in this
case, is actually
the class cry.
If you're unfamiliar with using
the plus in terms of
strings, it's just
a concatenator.
So play around with that in
IDLE if you're confused.
I would recommend copying all
of this into IDLE, and then
playing around with a particular
instantiation of
dogs, in this case, Lassie.
If you look at Lassie.name,
you'll end up going after
self.name, which is specified
when your
initialize the object.
So Lassie's name is Lassie.
Likewise, if you were to type
in Lassie.greeting, open
paren, close paren, and hit
Enter, you should get a string
return that says, "I'm Lassie,"
comma, "bark." Mostly
this is to familiarize you with
object oriented in Python
in the general sense.
Now, we're going to look at what
happens when you want to
set up a subclass.
If I set up class Retriever and
I want to inherit from the
super-class, Dog, I'm going
to pass in Dog.
This is in the same syntax that
I would use if it were a
function and I wanted to
pass in a parameter.
If I wanted to inherit from
multiple things or multiple
classes, I would put multiple
classes here.
Right now, we're just going
to inherit from Dog.
Note that I have no code here.
This is pretty much meant to
explicitly specify the fact
that Retriever is not actually
going to introduce any new
properties to dogs.
Their types are going
to be different.
So if I create something that's
a Retriever, it will be
of object type Retriever, versus
if I create something
and say, "Dog," open paren,
close paren, it's going to be
of type Dog.
But what happens when I
create a Retriever--
and as an aside, if you know who
Benji is, I know he's not
a retriever.
But bear with me here.
If I create a Retriever, it's
first going to look for an
initialization in any other
methods or attributes in the
Retriever class definition, run
any code that's here, and
then go to the parent class,
and run all the code here.
So even though Retriever did
not have any explicit code
underneath it, I can still
interact with the object,
Benji, the same way
that I interacted
with the object Lassie.
It has all the same methods and
all the same attributes.
Phew.
So there's basic inheritance.
And I will make another aside
that if you're doing this, you
probably don't need to create a
subclass in the first place.
If you're designing your own
code, and you're trying to
think about what the best way to
organize things is, if you
have to create a subtype or a
subclass and there are no new
methods or attributes or no
different ways of addressing
those methods or attributes,
then this category is probably
actually just this category.
You may want to make a
difference so that you can do
interesting things with
type checking.
I think that's the only thing
I can think of that would
justify it.
And I might be wrong.
Python gurus out there
should correct me.
But a thing to keep in mind.
So we've done the first half
of our inheritance.
We're going to inherit one more
time and create a class
of golden retrievers.
Once again, I've got my class
definition and my indication
that I'm going to inherit
from Retriever.
I don't have any initialization
or attribute
assignments.
I only have a definition
for greeting.
So what happens here?
Well, the first thing we always
do is look for an
initialization method.
Golden doesn't have one, so
it's going to check the
Retriever class.
Retriever doesn't have
one, so it's going to
check the Dog class.
The initialization
method is here.
So when it runs the
initialization method, it's
going to run this code.
The first thing that's going to
happen is any code, or any
attribute assignments, or method
definitions here are
going to be considered the
canon, or the first thing that
any Golden is going
to reference.
So greeting is going to be
executed before greeting used
in any other place.
You notice the only difference
between this greeting and the
Dog greeting is that
"OHAI!" has been
prepended to the phrase.
And the way that we end up doing
that is we refer to-- we
concatenate, and then refer
to the superclass.
And once again, we have to pass
in the explicit argument,
self, when we're talking about
a class definition.
Later, when you actually
instantiate an object and use
your parens, you're not
going to have to
put self as an argument.
It'll get confused.
We'll go over that
in a second.
So let's say I create a golden
retriever, Sidney.
I'm going to pass in one
argument, which is the name.
We're going to consider all the
definitions here first,
which means that goldens are
going to have a method for
greeting that is
specified here.
It's going to use the method for
greeting from Retriever.
And we could put in anything
here, right?
We could put Dog.greeting.
We could put in some other
function that is in the same
environment as class Golden.
But here, we can explicitly
access the superclass that we
defined here.
We're going to head over to
Retriever to see if there any
additional methods or attributes
that are a
consequence of being a subclass
of Retriever that we
need to add to our definition.
Now, we just hit the pass.
On the other hand, Retriever
inherits from Dog.
So once again, we have to jump
over to a super-class and grab
any attributes or methods that
are defined there as well.
So all the way back
over to Sidney.
When I call Sidney.greeting(),
the first thing that happens
is that I look in the most
specific subclass, or whatever
my object type is and
see if there's a
definition for the method.
Because there is, I'm not going
to use Dog.greeting().
I'm going to use
Golden.greeting().
Golden.greeting() says return
a string that says, "OHAI!"
And also append it to whatever
Retriever.greeting() returns.
I go over to Retriever.
It's not here, but I still
have a reference to Dog.
I go over to Dog.
It has a method for greeting.
And it says, "I'm Sidney.
Bark." So the final return
type should be, "OHAI.
I'm Sidney.
Bark."
This concludes my basic overview
of inheritance of
object-oriented programming
in Python for 6.01.
Next time, I'll review some
interesting features in Python
that actually originated in
earlier languages and also
particularly things in aliasing
that people that are
new to Python or people that
are new to programming find
especially confusing.